es el informe en primera plana la vista
de la residencia real de tailandia miles
de manifestantes se reunieron este
sábado pidiendo reformas al gobierno y
también a la monarquía para reforzar
nuestras instituciones empieza por
luchar en contra de una monarquía que
ejerce mucho poder
la monarquía per se no es un obstáculo
para la democracia y hay otros países
como el reino unido españa dinamarca
suecia o japón que tienen monarquías
pero la nuestra tiene mucho poder
es una posición valiente a tomar en un
país donde criticar a la familia real
puede resultar en una pena de 15 años de
prisión los manifestantes piden eliminar
esas restricciones y reducir los poderes
constitucionales del rey y también
solicitan la reducción de su fortuna
estimada en 40 mil millones de dólares
un movimiento liderado por estudiantes
pidió nuevas elecciones una nueva
constitución de renuncia del primer
ministro que llegó al poder en el golpe
de estado de 2014 el último en una
docena de intentos por derrocar al
monarca militar desde que el poder
absoluto real terminó en 1932 debemos
restablecer la democracia nuestra lucha
no puede ser el mal los manifestantes
afirmaron que planean continuar con las
protestas durante la noche para llegar a
la oficina del primer ministro del
domingo un plan que el gobierno les
aconsejó no realizar desde que llegó al
poder en 2016 el rey vajiralongkorn ha
pasado la mayoría de su tiempo en
alemania
[Aplausos]